WE GO BACK TO GERALDO WHO HAS
MORE NEWS THAT IS DEVELOPING.
GERALDO?
>> BREAKING, BREAKING NEWS.
THE HELICOPTERS ARE OVERHEAD.
THE AUSTIN POLICE DEPARTMENT
JUST TWEETED OUT, THERE WAS NO
PACKAGE EXPLOSION IN THE 9800
BLOCK OF BRODY LANE.
IT WAS AN INCENDIARY DEVICE.
I REPEAT, AN INCENDIARY DEVICES.
THEY HAVE NO EVIDENCE THEY'RE
RELATED.
SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS.
COULD THIS BE A SECOND ATTACKER?
A SECOND BOMBER --
>> Sean: GERALDO, HOW DO WE
INTERPRET WHAT AN INCENDIARY
DEVICE IS?
>> I WOULD IMAGINE LIKE A FLARE,
SOMETHING LIKE A FIRE WORK, SOME
KIND OF, YOU KNOW, MORE FLAME
THAN BANG.
AN EXPLOSION IS AN INCENDIARY
DEVICE.
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR THE ENERGY
TO GO.
AN INCENDIARY DEVICE IS MORE --
EFFORTING MORE SPECIFICS ON WHAT
THE INCENDIARY DEVICE CONSISTED
OF.
HOPEFULLY THE AUSTIN POLICE
DEPARTMENT WILL GIVE US SOME
GUIDANCE.
CLEARLY THERE WAS SOME KIND OF,
YOU KNOW -- MAYBE THE PERSON WAS
BURNED RATHER THAN BLOWN.
YOU KNOW, INJURED IN TERMS OF
THE EXPLOSION.
I'M JUST QUOTING FROM THE
POLICE.